talking about money issues can be
emotional
and uncomfortable and that's why on this
show
i would like to have those conversations
so
when i heard erin's story about her
student loan debt
i wanted to invite her here today hi
eric
hello drew erin will you please share
your money story sure um so
i'm recently engaged planning a wedding
i'm getting married soon
my fiance and i have dreams of buying a
home
and raising a family but you know i have
a lot of student loan debt about 100k
in student loan debt and then my fiance
has student loan debt
so we both had the idea to move in with
the in-laws try to save money
it isn't ideal it isn't romantic you
know for an engaged couple
but we're doing it because we know that
our future
it's important for our future and it's
necessary but peeling back a layer
will you talk about his mom
she's awesome um she's she's a wonderful
woman
i lost my mom about five years ago so
it's
nice to have a mother-in-law that's so
welcoming and so loving and caring for
me um
not being her own daughter what's her
name t
t d d yeah short for dolores oh my god
that's my grandmother's name
okay and everybody calls me d okay so
okay i'm
i just i loved the way you loved her
she's just like one of those people that
you meet and is the nicest person
wouldn't her to fly
um treats me like her own you know she's
she's awesome we're here also with our
friend of the show carmen rita wong and
i would like to get into some of the
financial aspects now that we've
established
the emotional mm-hmm carmen are you
there
yes lovely mama oh hi beautiful kindly
how are you
hello how are you so you know aaron is
not the only person obviously
going through this right now and has to
sort of
financially plan all of this carmen
what are your thoughts listen it's a lot
right
but aaron you're actually doing
something very very smart which is
you know you should at times like this
reach out to your community your friends
your family
over half of americans young adult
americans are now back to living
with their parents or their in-laws
right now so you are far
far from alone so debt and money is
neither bad nor good
it's all about how you frame it so the
frame here is
be proud of yourself you accomplish
something this is a monthly bill that
you're gonna have to take care of
but this is not necessarily something
bad it's just something to manage
how do you manage it though what is the
plan here
one of the easiest and best things to do
with that is to automate
so erin you have these student loans
right
if you automate those payments you have
income you and your fiance have income
coming in
so you know what's coming in if you can
automate those student loan payments you
can free up a lot of mental energy
you don't have to worry about them and
also too it'll help
build your credit and some lenders will
give you a little discount
on your interest rate maybe a quarter of
a percent it doesn't seem like much
with loans as big as yours for the life
of the loan we're talking thousands
of dollars so that's what you definitely
want to do you want to automate that
and i've got some really big news for
you in terms of your fiance
he's a public school teacher right right
yep he's a special ed teacher
oh my first of all wonderful hello
this is the thing if you work in the
public sector
you can have maybe not all your loans
forgiven
but big chunks we're talking over ten
thousand dollars and more
so go ahead encourage him or go with him
to studentaid.gov there are multiple
programs that he may qualify for to
forgive
his student loans okay it's big big
money it's good to know thank you
have you thought about having the
wedding somewhere else or saving money
on that and is this a battle worth
choosing
yeah well that's a good question so we
had thought about a small wedding
to save money for for that reason and
then it kind of just
went into you know but we do want that
big wedding so to speak
but out of budget so we are trying to
keep it low as best we can
we all have to make decisions on what is
important to us
and that cannot and should not be judged
by others
however carmen do you think that she is
going to have the steps
necessary to ever catch up
yes absolutely i'm going to tell you
also do another couple of things
that'll save you you can do today you
can do tomorrow that can save you
more money in addition to lowering your
interest in your student loans as well
there's more thousands of dollars your
credit card rates i want you to go and
negotiate
right to get to lower your credit card
rates i want you to go and negotiate
a lower car insurance your auto
insurance too you mentioned watching
your spending
that's very very important and this is a
very emotional time for you right you
know in terms of planning the wedding
and all that
be mindful of your emotions while you're
spending all of this is going to save
you some money i'm with drew here
when you want to commit to something
that's going to cost a bit more
sometimes that's like an investment in
you right
that's an investment in your sanity it's
an investment in your family
it's so important to you so you can make
it work
if you do the other part of it and it's
not so overwhelming if you take these
steps
day by day but just keep that plan in
mind
and the weirdest advice ever have a
sense of humor
about this money thing with your man so
that every time it flares
up its ugly head that you are in it
together against the world
yeah it's us it's just us against the
world exactly
um what's his name jim jim yeah
i did get a little bit interested in um
some of your
wedding planning i hope you don't mind
um i noticed that flowers seem to be
a high priority for you at your wedding
do you like flowers i love flowers can i
please buy your flowers for your wedding
yes okay oh my gosh okay
thank you um will you please check back
in with us
and with carmen i'm passionate about
your story
it really spoke to me and you know your
love of your mom
and where you're at and carmen's right
there are so many people
living with their families and i did
that with my family and honestly it was
some of the happiest memories i've ever
had in my entire life yeah yeah
erin as one of a family of six who also
has lost her mother
i'm here for you i believe in you and i
want you to get this done
so after the show we're gonna get
together and we're gonna work on this
great thank you we're totally rooting
for you and jim thank you so much for
coming on the show and sharing thank you
thank you carmen thank you i love you
thank you so much
you